i heard you had your hand in everything
like from the way somebody would pull a
gun out to you you and james would talk
back and forth constantly
yeah uh me and james is you know there
there's a a
a love of film and music so
you know it doesn't feel like work when
we when we're bouncing ideas off each
other you know it's just like you know
talking shop
one in three cowboys in the west was
black people don't know that
and so what did it mean to make this
western so when people see this western
when kids click on netflix they'll look
at this and they'll hear those names
also yeah i just love to be a part of
projects that widen the lens you know
because once it's widened for us then
it's widened for you know asian for
you know mexican for everyone uh right
so you know the idea of and this again
one in three so this really exists and
people really think that you know i mean
you can't fault them because that was
the images we were fed going growing up
like one of the only things on you know
public television was westerns every
week you would get western so
um and we weren't we weren't represented
in those in those at all um in fact you
know you know our characters was taken
from us you know the lone ranger was
based on you know one of the characters
from this film
i think of that iconic picture of nat
love that you know you see and you're
like wait a minute this dude really was
a man who changed the west yeah yeah
yeah trudy smith uh you know
every single one of them yeah
the soundtrack how much fun was it
putting your fingers in that too and
changing the narrative of the music we
hear with the west
yeah we you know we just love to like
been things and uh uh play with the
music and put you know sound beds over
things that people don't think is like
typical like typical sounds you hit that
barrington levy you know it makes total
sense to us
um but you know you know the average
person you know you get you get to
the average listener yeah you know it's
like wait those two things don't go
together
they totally do they totally do it yeah
and that was the fun part the fun part
was like been in genres and like um you
know creating with cuddy and uh
you know all these things and yeah the
family out tonight is a family affair i
saw your mother-in-law so proud of you
yeah yeah we're going we yeah
we support each other that's what we do